all right hot breath averse it is
happening welcome back to hot breath
podcast the show where you learn comedy
from the pros you are watching our hot
breath live series comedians on skype
talking comedy if you're watching on
YouTube all of these questions are being
asked in our Facebook group so just go
to the link in the description click
that join the Facebook group and you get
access to comedians like today's guest
who is the one and only Ron Funches
ladies and gentlemen give a round of
applause to Robby bunches thank you this
is so great so I love
we're already smiling and we're about to
jump into the Q&A but I of course have
to selfishly ask at least a few
questions as a fan and as a fellow
comedian and what I would always look
for in community is like what can we
learn about them even just beyond how
you tell a joke and something I admire
about you is just your mindset and I'm
curious as a comedian not only just
mental health but what is the value of
having your mindset and how does your
offstage mindset affect your onstage
performance and that's the question that
I'm gonna try to take my time with if
you don't mind
absolutely well it kind of came to me
pretty early in comedy from going to
open mics I would see different types of
styles and I would see people especially
when I started it was during you know
the bush years in people who loved to do
politics jokes then and they loved to
just make fun of him and and rip him
apart and I would see these acts and I
remember seeing one guy in particular he
seemed so angry and so like really
invested in it and then I see him
offstage and I was like wow like oh you
really get so angry about that I mean I
must suck that suckers like but that
must be hard for you to live with and
he's like oh I don't really feel that
way you know it's an
and I was like oh well then why did you
do it you know that's how I looked at it
and I looked at the job and I understood
that it wasn't like it wasn't always
improv you know it wasn't coming up with
a new joke every time you went onstage
you might work on some wording you might
change things up but a lot of the times
you know you're working on your act over
and over and over again and so I decided
that if I wanted if I had to say the
same things over and over again that I
wanted to talk about things I loved and
I want to talk about things that made me
happy not things that I didn't want to
give power to things that I hate it you
know I feel that the Trump election was
a big indicator of that like you had
right up until he was elected everyone
was like oh she's a joke he's an idiot
he's this he's that he's just a reality
star but I could tell just from the
amount of talk in the universe it was
all about him whether it was negative or
positive it was about him and to me when
you do that you give that entity a lot
of power and so I wanted to like if I
want to bring power to things I want to
bring power to things that I love and
enjoy things that some people make fun
of like you know pro wrestling or video
games or monogamy or whatever like
things that I like and that I enjoy I'd
rather give them more power than they
can constantly be like oh can you
believe this is going on you know and I
think there's still a value to that
there's always a value to speaking truth
to power and calling out [ __ ] and I
try never to shy away from that but I
didn't want to I didn't never wanted my
stage life in my real life to be far
apart from each other I felt that the
most successful comedians and the people
who I looked up to were people who who
would be joking around backstage and
then get on stage and be the same exact
person how are you able to how that
that's something as commands we struggle
with is like we want to be funny
offstage like we
are on stage how were you able to like
tighten that gap over time preparing
this day she doesn't she'll get weirded
out by because oh heavens it's set and
she's like what are you gonna do and I
just like I don't know like I'll figure
it out when I get up there and so I a
lot of it came from reading and watching
Garry Shandling's documentary in
biography of staying in the moment and
trying not to like show people like this
is an act you know I wanted to I once I
watched that documentary I started to
set this rule of myself that I would
always start by just being in the moment
I would never start with like a planned
joke I would always just talk about what
at whatever's going on awesome and some
of some of the questions are more about
like going in more detail on that so
I'll just jump into my next question
real quick because another thing that I
admire about you is your mindfulness
around learning and being a part of
other worlds besides just comedy we can
we can get single-minded as comedians to
be like it's all comedy all the time but
you're very intentional about learning
from different worlds and being in
different worlds and I recently heard
you say in an interview that you've
learned more about the business from
like rap and wrestling than you have
from anything within comedy and I would
be interested to know what are some of
the business things you've learned from
rap and wrestling that you apply to your
comedy oh thank you for asking that I
think in comedy we a lot of us get this
mindset of like oh we're pure artists we
just want to do stand-up like so many my
friends I'd even talk to and if like why
do you want to do voice acting well you
want to do like like stand-up is the
purity and I think if anyone sees right
now diversify
and your portfolio is a [ __ ] god
because there's no stage for you to hit
right now but however I'm still getting
checks from trolls but I don't either
here nor there I learned from from rap
and from from wrestling was
self-promotion about making yourself
seem like a big deal that if you made
yourself seem like a big deal no one's
gonna believe you are a big deal until
you do and so a lot of my like I would
post about my shows I would post about
what's going on even if they were half
full I would just take pictures I would
post about them because I was like you
want to be a part of this people the
half full room that was here they loved
it you should be here they are the cool
people and then a lot of it was like
selling t-shirts and sellin posters like
when I started doing that a lot of it
was kind of looked down upon that it was
corny that it was hacky that was that's
what role comics do but I knew every
time I went to a wrestling show every
time I went to a rap show I wanted to
leave with that artist this t-shirt
because I wanted to support them because
I wanted to mmm
I thought it was cool if I came back
with a currency shirt or Devin the Dude
shirt or whatever like and I thought it
was weird that comics didn't seem look
at it like that and so I wanted I got
into merch more I got into
self-promotion more and I got into
making like little commercials for my
[ __ ] for my runs from my tour like I
said they're doing that a couple years
ago and a lot of my comedian peers were
making fun of me like hey why are you
doing that it's you know you're wasting
your time if they're stupid they're
low-budget they look weird but I like I
love low-budget commercials it is a
little it's a local commercial for like
hey I'm coming to your town and I [ __ ]
you not like a year later clubs were
requiring that I send them a video and
then my and then I started seeing oh my
parents are making commercials now wait
and I was like oh you
you are the one making fun of me I was
like you know when it comes to business
I don't like to be a follower I like to
be a leader I like to think about what
we could do different what we can do
better that's one thing I'm doing right
now I'm partnering with this company
pro-wrestling T's comm and they've been
a big help in the pro wrestling
community with helping independent
contractors independent wrestlers sell
their own merch online they provide the
t-shirts they provide like the shipping
they provide everything you just provide
the art you set the price point and it's
been such a godsend for the wrestling
community I was like why don't we have
this for comedians we probably sell more
shirts than wrestlers and so now we're
starting at we got a small group of
people me Adam ray Brad Williams Billy
Wayne Davis Jackie fabulous best-selling
and we're starting like a comedy
wrestling tease with with the pro
wrestling tease guy so because I think
it can work for comedians of all levels
because they don't when I started
selling merch like they they would make
you buy a bow colder or t-shirts I
remember I was selling with some small
company and I sold like 300 shirts and
they sent me a bill and I was like
what's going on you know so luckily I
stuck because of my love of pro
wrestling I was able to talk to this
other company that was like hey that's
[ __ ] ridiculous like you'll never you
come hang out with us you'll never get a
bill for a sell in a shirt weight you
might you know when we get five ten
dollars if you sell one shirt that month
but you'll never get a bill and so I've
been working with them and building that
relationship ever since what I love is
that you weren't taking into like the
negativity of like well why are you
doing that that's dumb that's hack I
mean I've definitely heard what were you
selling merch what are you a traveling
salesman or something you know and we
all heard that but you were mindful
enough to be like well no this is my
journey this is my career that I'm in
control of my success and I'm going to
do this regardless of whatever chatter
I'm hearing yeah to me is no different
than high school you know it's like no
know what we're doing we're all trying
to figure it out we all want that so
what in what do we do we just all sit
around and make fun of each other you
know so like to me I started looking at
that as a positive like if I was doing
something and I could tell that my peers
were kind of mocking it I was like oh
I'm on that something oh yeah that
that's a gold right there so I'm
definitely gonna mark that one down I'm
gonna glaze that on a plate and hang it
in my office
so let's let's get into these uh these
questions here and I first have to say
as soon as my sister saw that you were
gonna be on here she was like messaging
me this morning she was so excited she's
a huge fan but then she has a daughter
that didn't nap this afternoon so I
guess that means that it gets crazy if
there's no nap in the middle of the day
so she couldn't make it but she sent me
a message just to start off this Q&A
with some positivity as we like to do
she just said I would like to tell him
that I loved undateable and have wanted
a Shelly hug ever since then and we have
also loved him in trolls and it was
awesome to see Cooper have such a major
role in the trolls World Tour movie
thank you I really appreciate that I
really like that too because I got to
not just do silly voices I got to
actually act and have a little story to
tell so that means a lot to me thank you
beautiful all right so this actually
transitions perfectly into that this is
our first question from Christian
Williams asks can you speak on making
the transition from stand-up to acting
and voice acting and what is your
favorite show or movie you've gotten to
work on oh okay yeah first I will say
that like it's so they're so different
they're very different jobs and but what
you was different about them is just
kind of like the technical speak and and
not knowing terms it's kind of like it's
a lot of different industries like
whether you're in the medical industry
or your alloy
there's these terms that you know that
other you know civilians don't know so
when I first was going from stand up to
acting there were things that scared me
like when people say hey turn camera
side I didn't know what that meant
hit your hit your mark I did not know
what that meant and so that was the
scary part of it but coming from stand
up it gave me this background of like
okay I can look at it I can look at
these scenes like jokes and I can look
at my my my lines as they're my set list
you know and I've done that kind of what
everything I do I try not to betray my
base in my background like even when I
write I try to write my own series I try
to write different so if you prop pilots
but if you go into my initial like
drafts they're kind of like sets they're
just like this this is the order this is
the end this is you know it's one two
three four like it's a set because I
that's how I learned to write and so I
kind of take that with acting and voice
acting as well one of the biggest
lessons I learn and some of the best
advice I can give is to stay humble and
to not think success in one area means
that you have success in the other area
but that it does mean that you can have
a base like I know I'm funny so I was
like okay that I can learn the rest I
know I'm funny I know I'm likable I'm
know I'm people want to watch me so I
the rest I can learn and that's what I
would say learn it go to acting class
have a respect for it if you truly want
to do it because that that's what I did
soon as I moved to LA within six months
I was in acting class and I've been in
acting class continuously since then
like I don't I don't leave like I I know
I don't have a respect for people who
don't respect the craft like to me it's
such a blessing to have these jobs to
have that opportunity and I always know
I hated it when an actor or wrestler or
somebody came in to stand up and then
they were like oh yeah I'm right we
talked to some wrestlers and I go I try
to stand up the first show I did was an
hour and he's just like well you didn't
you didn't really do Santa you told some
stories until you left you know so like
I don't have respect for that and I knew
I didn't want to be that as an actor I
didn't want to come in and have actors
be like oh this guy doesn't he's just
mugging and just hitting lines he's
nothing
Kerry doesn't know about the arc he
doesn't know about intentions he doesn't
know anything like that so I stay in
class and I think when the major
difference that my acting teacher taught
me was that and it helped my standup
actually is that stand-ups are usually
taught to stay above their feelings and
to just comment on the situation and
that doesn't work for acting you have to
be in your body you have to be in your
feelings you have to go on the journey
you know that's why Seinfeld is a great
comedian and great on his show but he's
not a great actor because he doesn't go
into the any feelings and so I learned
that I wanted to do that and then I kind
of would say oh like I can take those
feelings and then use that in my
stand-up so now I'm not only getting
laughs I'm taking you on this journey
I'm making you feel I make him talking
to you about my son I'm talking to you
about my life I'm making you care about
me and to me that's like just as
powerful as getting a big laugh and know
that no that was very thorough thank you
so much for sharing that because I which
was the favorites my favorites that I've
done so far I really loved acting with
Dan Harmon I did a thing with him called
great minds where I got to be Idi Amin
and just his process of like when I
showed up there they didn't even have a
script like he was just like these this
is what we're thinking about let's work
it out together
and then we'll figure it out and I feel
like it was probably some of my best
acting because of that
I really like my role in future man
because I liked I thought I did some
solid acting there and I say my
voiceover is Harley Quinn like I I think
that's like super funny in a really good
show and and just some of my best work
awesome so the next question we have
here we have from a Devon Stanfield and
he asks how important was the weight
loss in weight how important was the
weight how important was the weight loss
important for you I was like wait am I
reading this right answer that question
how I feel how I feel it's be an ass
it's just important my life for for my
health first and foremost like that's
what I cared about is that I knew I
wasn't doing that health being
healthiest we're having a lot having
trouble breathing sometimes like doing
two shows a night would not like take it
out of me and I was just like especially
once I got on the show I was like oh oh
holy [ __ ] like I'm got this show I don't
know what I'm doing you know like I
don't know what I'm doing at all so what
would happen if I buckled down and put
forth an effort and not just acting
class but also my health and I just knew
like there was a limit to the roles that
I was gonna get at that weight I was at
like 350 plus at that time I knew there
was a limit to my roles that I would
that the highest that I was probably
gonna get was gonna be fat friend you
know and I felt in my heart that I was
more than that that I was a leading man
and I was like hey I'm willing to do
anything to allow me to have more range
that allowed me the people to look at me
a little bit different and at first
it was a negative because I was
affecting sometimes my shows like I
would go out with my new face and new
promo and people be like I don't know
who that is
well that's not Ron Funches you know and
then also you get the classic oh you're
not you're fat you're not fat as much
anymore so there's no way you're funny
you know and I was just like well who
gives a [ __ ] cuz now I'm healthy and I
love you like I I know in my mind I'm a
leading man and that goes back to you
saying no one's gonna think you're a big
deal until you think you're a big deal
it's just right here and it's so
powerful yeah and I want that and I knew
that the weight was gonna be a big big
hurdle for that to be the scene of the
Lina man and in for a while again it was
a short-term negative but I start I knew
it's starting to work when I would get
some of these roles like an even like
there was like this in-between time
where I was still getting like hey we
want you to be the fat guy rolls and I
was this janitor for the show ap bio and
they wanted me to hit on this lady and
and and then she turned me down
and then I went and I did it and then
they called cut and the director was a
wonderful woman I've worked with a
couple times she just was like hmm we're
gonna need you to like hold a plunger or
something because I'm just not seeing
why she wouldn't go out with you this is
the best note I've ever received because
when I was 360 pounds I never got that
note that's perfect alright next one
here from Wayne flake junior are there
any writing techniques that you have
found most helpful just to write
everyday you know I like the free write
in the morning just get some ideas out I
usually call my writing style more more
fishing than hunting you know I'm not
necessarily like oh this is what we're
doing I kind of like sit and I let
things come to me
and then so it's very slow in that way
but I think one of my favorite
techniques when I don't have anything
like when I'm like oh I need to just
come up with a topic is I'll take the
grid and I will just write love hate
fear and then I will go to what do I
love right now what do I hate right now
what do I fear right now and I know if I
can come up with something that pulls
those emotions out of me then those are
probably subjects I should write about
and talk about on stage so you'll list
out some things on there love hate fear
and then you may pick one and start free
writing about it is that kind of the
distillation yes exactly and then from
free writing you then have whittled that
down into maybe a few phrases or ideas
that then you take to the stage or do
you get even more specific on the word
forward yeah I have it's the idea you
know once I have the idea then I put it
on stage and I always say that like I
don't know I don't know the idea the
audience will tell me what the joke is
you know when they laugh then the joke
has stopped right right but is that a
skill that you worked in too cuz a lot
of the times younger comics are like
I'll just go up there and figure it out
because this professional comic of 30
years said to that's what he does like
is it something you worked into or were
you always just do definitely you should
have some years of experience first I
mean but I think that's how like you
know what any experience any job you
just feel more comfortable when I first
started I had to write full ass scripts
you know like they were word-for-word
what I was going to say but that made me
a bad performer because I you know I
wasn't even thinking about laughs I
wasn't even thinking about like oh I'm
had to stop here you know I just had a
monologue basically and then I stopped
writing like that and then I would just
start writing kind of like a grocery
list where just be like oh this is the
subject this is the subject this is the
subject
I'm gonna talk about it and I might have
a punchline in mine or I might have a
setup in mind but I usually didn't have
Bo you know talk it out and then just
you know see if sometimes bomb but
sometimes people laugh and I go oh okay
that's how I should say it next time
perfect and you mention grocery list
which comes in to Jason Fox's question
he asked what is your pre-show routine
so is it you making that grocery list
yeah what is the pre-show routine um
lately it's changed my pre-show routine
in the past and it depends on what I got
going on and I'm working on towards an
hour
am I like sharpening something out
because then I might have that list I
might have full index cards of like
here's my whole set here's where I think
is weak here is what I think I need to
work on here's what I think is done even
though it usually never is but a lot of
times lately it is because my my special
came out and then I was kind of like oh
now I just want to do comedy for fun
again like that was such a stressful
time of like run it run it run it run it
run it and then I was like oh [ __ ] I did
it I achieved my personal goal I made an
hour comedy and I [ __ ] like it so now
because I know a lot of people they're
like oh next hour next hour next hour
but to me that's so mentally draining I
was just like now I get to just write
about whatever [ __ ] it's great and
it's fun and so now I just kind of talk
[ __ ] with my friends we usually bring
like a little speaker system even better
now I kind of make the clubs do a
playlist of the songs that I want to
listen to instead of listening to their
music you know because I'm trying to set
my tone and set what we're gonna do for
the evening so the music's playing me
and my friends are usually just chatting
and having
the time and I'm laying down chilling
like my best set if I'm not even
thinking about it until I get on stage
mmm all right so the next we have from
Chase Bonin he said hi or maybe Bannen I
don't know we'll call a Bannen I don't
know we'll call a bone and I like we're
just roasted a few people that are
asking questions great so yesterday
Jesse David Fox was roasting someone's
name too so I guess people are expecting
it now so he asks with such a unique
style do you ever find yourself still
having similar jokes with any other
comics the whole parallel thinking thing
of course yeah yeah not all the time but
sometimes I was in Montreal having a
good time doing some jokes about koalas
and had koalas have chlamydia because I
found that out when I went to Australia
and then I went to go see
Gosei Sloane afterwards and she was
pretty much doing the same exact
business I talked to her afterwards and
I was just like hey like I just wanna
let you know I'm doing a koala bit about
going to Australia you're doing
chlamydia like they were different
different like arcs on it but for the
most part it's just like koalas
chlamydia and so I was like I don't plan
to stop I don't think I'm gonna put it
in anything but I it's funny and fun so
I'm gonna keep working on it you keep
working on yours I just want to let you
know I'm doing it and then most of all I
just love their two young black
comedians both went to Australia oh yes
you just keep writing about it you're
like even though someone else is doing
it I'm still gonna do my version of it
yeah I mean you know there's a
difference of like street jokes and like
one to one just copies but if you're
talking your life you're talking
relationships you're talking things
you're there's nothing new Under the Sun
you know so you're gonna run into the
same topics I think a lot of comedians
do themselves a disservice by
like not wanting to talk about the
mundane not talk wanting to talk about
subjects that have been done before but
it's like your view if it's truthful and
if there's your reality then I want to
hear that - I want to hear that like I
love that especially as I get older and
like I'm like oh like there's these 20
year old comics talking about drugs I've
never heard before and sexual positions
I've never done before and so I should
probably just talk about being a
homeowner and the things I'm doing yeah
that's that to them
we had a Alonzo Bodden on here who is
known to be great at topical humor and
his his whole thing was to make it
uniquely you is to put it through your
point of view that's basically how you
make any general topic unique to you in
your voice yeah just talk about what you
know about you know and that's the thing
I hate the most is when you see
comedians and they like oh this is a
topic everybody's talking about so I
need to talk about it and a lot of times
like nothing worse to me than like
seeing someone do a store like some male
comic doing jokes about abortion that
never experienced that never took
someone to go get one never went through
that thing like to mean though like the
exact opposite is like I don't know if
you've heard it I assume Anthony
Jeselnik sabor Shin joke about taking a
lady to the abortion clinic like it's a
sweet joke it's a hilarious joke it's a
mean joke just like he likes to do but
it's truthful and it's honest and that's
what I love about it instead of someone
just doing an abortion joke because they
think it's a taboo subject to talk about
beautiful alright speaking of taboo
topics here Luke lyndale asks how much
clean time do you have versus non clean
time and do you try to have a specific 1
to 1 ratio
no I don't think about it I don't really
think about it all and in fact I usually
people have to tell me them somewhat
clean
like I'll get out to do clean shows in
my manager be like yeah gonna do it and
I'm like do I have that many minutes to
clean material but I think as you get
more experience in comedy you learn does
not even necessarily about the words
it's not about [ __ ] and [ __ ] it's about
intention it's about voice it's about
tone and so a lot of times like I don't
consider myself clean at all but other
people do just because of my tone you
know just because I my snake is sweet
they're like you know he's in Clinton
but I'm not so I don't I don't really
think about it I think you know that if
you're if you were leaning that way
there's nothing wrong with that I don't
think that being mindful of what words
you use is never a bad thing you never
want to like just be cursing just
because I that's the thing that I'm
really into his word economy and just
being wordsmith and another thing I take
from wrestling because I was a big fan
of wrestlers like Bret Hart and Shawn
Michaels who like everything that they
did mattered and so I kind of try to
take that in same way comedy like every
word I use I want to matter I don't want
to just be throwing out arms and shits
and [ __ ] just because I want everything
I do to be having intention and I think
if you write that way it doesn't really
matter if you're clean or dirty but you
know cleaner you are the more money you
probably get I don't know what is that
editing process where you start to iron
out those ohms and filler words and
really get that word economy tight
everything is like does this matter
oh and in my writing I always stopped
any time I if the word because came into
my sentence I was like oh I've talked
too much and you know if I have to get
into where I'm explaining it where I'm
like did it lit up because of this then
I've not explained well you know like I
should be able to explain it without
getting into a secondary because so I
started looking at that and being like
okay if that's in here than I need
find a way to sharpen it if there's a
curse word in here can it be replaced
I learned a lot of that from from from
JP buck actually who is the producer for
for Conant and the first time I worked
with him I liked a lot of myself have
much more curse words in it and he was
just like well what if you did this what
if you did that what if you you know
what if this is a funnier way of saying
it and and are you alright was like wow
like you a lot of times cursing and
being dirty is a way of being lazy and
so if I find a way to get the same idea
across with a funnier word or made-up
word even then that was more fun than
just saying [ __ ] or [ __ ] now sometimes I
need if the punchline is [ __ ] you or
that like I don't know I don't believe
in going Oh Frick you or useless you
know son of a B I don't believe in that
I'd like if you if the curse word is
there it needs to be there like [ __ ]
Linda forget Linda right now exactly
alright yeah and I love to ear a word
Smith too but beyond the word Smith
you're also your performance is it's so
unique to you and is actually is from
Patrick Fowler asks you've talked about
how you stay soft smoke spoken to pull
in the audience while on stage how did
you develop that art in a bar slash Club
crowd that is being loud and
uninterested yeah learning to stop
caring about them hmm it's one of the
best lessons I learned was from doing
shows at Sookie's bar in Portland Oregon
which is the tiny notoriously like they
just would not even look at you they
would just be talking the whole time and
you had to learn to keep your rhythm and
to make yourself laugh and to in that if
you cap your rhythm even though they
weren't talking to you simply by the
fact that they could
like did a little pause did it pause it
would make them turn because mentally
they're just like oh there's a rhythm
happening here and so it was kind of
like you know
Goku training in a thousand of time
gravity or some [ __ ] like that you know
where you just learn to like make
yourself happy make yourself laugh and
to to keep your own rhythm and not care
about that because yet again I would try
to scream over them or started a joke by
yelling and then go soft but by the end
I think you know I learned a lot of it
from watching TIG Notaro I saw her one
time at a after show its Bumbershoot at
the crocodile in Seattle and everyone it
was an after party show and so everyone
is really loud even the comedians were
talking over the show and she came out
and she refused to talk over a whisper
and she would just scoot the stool
around onstage making a slight screech
so people could hear and then she was
just to her jokes real softly and when I
saw that I was like holy [ __ ] like
there's such a power in maintaining your
stone your speech level and not changing
it for the circumstance because when
you're changing it for the circumstance
you're giving your power to that
audience when you come in with your
rhythm your level you're telling them
hey this is what I do this is who I am I
don't change for you get on board or not
and there's such a power there is such a
like likability to that that when I saw
take do that it kind of like open my
eyes right away like oh I don't have to
yell I can be completely me I can be
completely soft I even now like I hold
the mic almost to my chest because I
want people to like have to listen
because I I'm just not loud I can't get
loud but I prefer not to yeah and
there's a confidence like a quote I
heard you say is like don't be afraid to
let the audience get to know you which
is something you learn from the Sklar
brothers because a lot of times if the
opening joke misses I used early on if
my opening joke missed I would turn
around
and start like rubbing the wall and just
I guess this sets over but there is a
power to just keep doing your rhythm and
keep going and they'll come to you yeah
yeah let people coming to you because it
it just makes sense
mentally especially with the way the
system is set up if you're opening if
you're featuring why would they care
about you they're taught they're taught
you have that you know change their mind
you have to show them that you're
valuable you have to show them that with
they listen to you they're getting the
next big person you know and so the best
way to do that is just kind of know who
you are right away know that you're good
know that you're gonna get better
you know that like this set isn't the
end-all be-all that's one of the best
lessons I learned from being able to do
some acting and voiceover work is now
club owners club managers don't scare me
I'm like what are you running oh you're
gonna not book me okay like fine you
know mm-hmm
once you lose that fear once you kind of
like room remember that this is not a
job this is not a job this is a treat
this is your passion this is your fun
this is
same thing when I learn with auditions
it took me a long time and still
sometimes I forget it but when I started
going like oh I'm not in here with them
they're in here with me I get to show
them what I think this character is and
if they like it they like it if they
don't they don't but this is what I
think this character is auditioning came
a lot more fun than me being like oh
please like me please you know what do
you want me to do what do you think I
should do you know all right we have
Dana rimoni here says hi Mountie ya
rimoni rabboni if we're gonna tag off
bounine oh gosh that was a weak callback
let's move on hi Ron fellow Mackay Roy
Scot class of 96 meow cheer oh so it's
how hard is it to truly be original with
your joke writing when it seems like a
lot of comedians just regurgitate the
same or similar premises oh it sounded
like that was a diss wrapped in a
question but I understand the spirit of
it I think it's something that a Liza
Schlesinger said that got people really
upset at the time that I had kind of
agreed with but I think she she kind of
just said it in the wrong term because I
think she said 80% of female comedians
doing the same act but and which made a
lot of women mad but what she should
have said is 80% of comedians are doing
the same act and because that's what you
see you see people following you see
trends I'm sure any mic you go to any
show you go to you can start to see the
trends and like a while ago it was like
kale and [ __ ] talking about
transgender people and then for a while
I remember when I was really pissed
because it was people they knew they
couldn't say the word [ __ ] anymore
so they started to use the word autistic
and I was like okay well you're still
you're still a [ __ ] shitty person
that coming from your voice these trends
because you know that's just how life is
but my favorite comedians and the way I
try to write is like if I see those
trends then I'm like okay I'm not gonna
write about that I'm gonna go the other
way or I will go a lot about what the
way I write which is kind of [ __ ] ish
is lately is I'll go to the comedy store
and I'll listen to people talk about
things and I'll disagree with them and
then I'll write about how I disagree
with them
so I like I'll go see like Neal Brennan
when my favorite it's one of the best
joke writers in the world and he does a
lot of jokes about like why you
shouldn't get married why you shouldn't
have children that you should say single
and so I started writing all these jokes
about why he was wrong anyway he's a
[ __ ] idiot and way like hey what the
[ __ ] you got going on you're a rich
white man you can't add a little
responsibility to your life you wouldn't
even have to raise the baby you'd be
asleep half the time I think some of the
ways that I'm original is that a lot of
my comedy is me being a contrarian to
what I see to whatever bothers me
whatever trends that I'm seeing so I
think that helps and also I just never
try to write anything that isn't out of
my personal life that isn't my personal
feelings like sometimes they'll maybe
wrapped in a little you know joke that
isn't true but for the most part if I
said I'd [ __ ] minute like I do these
jokes lately about how I hate the news
and I'll only watch Rugrats and that's
true Who I am and so I think that's what
makes you original that's what sets you
apart is if you don't go I think when we
were younger comedians you kind of go
like what's the style of joke I can
write I need to write an abortion joke I
need to write a relationship joke I need
to write it this type of joke and I
stopped doing that and just more start
thing about what's going on with me
what's going on in my life how do I feel
right now and then I just start talking
about that so like my special was a lot
of like oh like my life is changing
things are different like things are
going different from me then they were
before let's talk about that and then
what my hour now mostly is like holy
[ __ ] I'm happy I'm really happy and
these are the reasons why I think I'm
gonna get married again and that's weird
so let's talk about that and talk about
the difference between me my fiancee now
and me being married
20s like to me and it's like okay that's
like real highly relatable but highly
unique you know and then I've been doing
a lot of talking about the weight losses
let me open up more about like eating
addictions and my own things that I was
embarrassed about and that's another
that's one of my truest advice that I
could give is that if something
embarrasses me if I feel a tinge of like
ooh I don't I don't know if I want to
talk about that I lean into it and then
I write about it because that has always
proven to pull the best material for me
and in the beginning of that was doing
jokes about my son having autism I
didn't want to do those jokes I thought
I they made me sad a little bit talking
about it and I didn't want people to
think I was making fun of my son I
didn't want to think that people think I
was making fun of autism I I mean I
remember the one that for us the first
times I told him another comic came out
to me like oh I like those jokes about
your [ __ ] kid and I was like you
don't get what I'm doing at all oh my
god wow that's gold though if something
embarrasses me I lean into it
Wow so we have we have arrived at the 45
minute mark here kiddos as we land this
plane here for not you got a feel for
the show that you dropped a bomb on us
there with if something embarrasses me I
lean into it do you have any other
closing advice for comedians out there
that you've learned over your career
yeah I think the main thing I can think
about is mostly just applies to right
now is that you truly have to love what
you do and not care about the money and
I care about success or fame like if
that's what your goal is with this then
you you might want to move on because is
the long road it's a slow road if you're
gonna try to be really good at it and as
you know as of probably a couple months
ago the bubble has burst so you you have
to do
you love and that's to me that's how I
started because because of starting in
Portland there wasn't this blueprint of
like oh we have Portland comics that
have made it and become super famous and
this is how you do it
like the most famous comics in Portland
at the time we're doing like these
tribal runs and these gigs through Idaho
and Montana and I knew from the get-go I
didn't want to go do that [ __ ] so I was
just like I guess I'm just writing for
me I'm just I'm just writing what I
think is funny and I think that helped
me find my voice so much quicker than
trying to emulate and trying to copy
what has worked before I just kind of
like was a little mold of mashed
potatoes and was just like this is what
I think is funny and slowly I got better
at explaining it and better at getting
my point across and that's been mostly
the journey is less like gaining
knowledge and gaining skills and more
unlocking who I truly am and and the
closer I get to my true self it seems
the more successful I become and the
better I get at it and I just try to
start following those rules of what
works for me
because I would use to not eat well not
sleep well not meditate because I was
like oh that's stupid but I was like
holy [ __ ] when I follow these rules my
life just gets better so my main advice
would be follow the [ __ ] rules don't
think you're above the rules follow the
rules eat well sleep well get on stage
have fun right do the nerd work do this
stuff afterwards where you're listening
to your set and breaking it down do all
of it because it's not all it's not all
about being on stage that's like 10% of
the job the rest of it is what you do
with the rest of your day you know and
you can be lazy or you can be a [ __ ]
craftsman with it and that's what I like
to do yeah and you really are just a
winning example for us comics to think
beyond just grinding at open mics it's a
vet it's important and you need to do
that to develop the skill but what else
can you do can you act voiceover podcast
you're now doing this show with kwibi
called nice one
that's a
game show where comedians try to out
complement each other which is another
part of your point of view and you've
your voice and you've just been able to
instill your voice into everything you
do which i think is so valuable for
comics to see a successful version of
that for us to aspire I really
appreciate that that's a beautiful
compliment but I do want to turn it into
a little bit of advice just because when
you work so hard at being a comedian for
like 10-15 well however many years and
then you might get a chance at doing a
little bit of acting and do things you
do want to be aware of what you're
taking and obviously of course you can't
be like oh you know I need to be the
leading man but you do want to be aware
of what your brand is and what what you
want to put out there which is why like
I try not to like take roles as some
super serious gang member or take a role
as like I got offered this role to be
this guy who was like he was funny but
he was a misogynist and I was like well
that's okay if I was a regular actor if
I was just an actor and I was going from
part to part to part and people were
just like well okay I like them in this
I like them in that that's fine but I'm
selling me so when I didn't sell me I
need to me to be represented in
everything I do
so when I take a role I look for that
person do is there me in that role and
I've been so blessed when when people
are like hey we don't even have a name
for this character I'm always like well
then his name's Ron punches that back to
the road you know like oh who played
that guy no that's Ron Funches oh you
know yeah and there's a that and that
was the best best gifts that Nick Kroll
gave me when I was playing his lawyer
and stuff when I was first kind of like
getting any type of recognition that he
made sure that he was just wrong and he
would even you know talk I mean like
c-czar said this thing there all right
[ __ ] with Ron Funches and that has like
stuck with me since then and to her like
I go to these college shows and
to be like oh I [ __ ] love Kroll show
I [ __ ] with Ron Funches you know oh well
we here's red [ __ ] with Ron Funches as
well we thinks for taking the time to do
this yeah what what all would you like
to promote here how can we go support
you I'm fine you've got troll money kids
he doesn't need us but it would help
some of my friends and me is if you just
check out that kwibi showing nice one
you can get a free trial I don't need
you to pay for it if you go it's coming
out June 1st I got a lot of friends that
wrote on it laughing worked on it it's
my first time hosting something and I
like I fell in love with hosting like is
similar to like when I was first doing
stand-up and then I found acting and I
was like oh holy [ __ ] like stand-up is
my first kid but like acting is another
child and then I found out I really like
hosting I like making other comics look
good I like I like the premise of the
show which is kinda to lift comedy up I
get so mad at things like the roasts and
things like that where great comedians
are helping shitty celebrities look
funny I don't like that I'm not into
that Martha Stewart is not [ __ ] funny
Mike Lawrence is funny because he wrote
her joke you know like she who doesn't
know what to do I want to take comedians
and that's what I would this show is
like it gave me the chance to compliment
them but I'd also be like hey these are
their credits they've been on this
they've been on that they do this and I
don't think as comedians we do that
enough we don't go like I'm great I've
done this I [ __ ] did that we don't
we're taught to hide that and so I want
in this show when the best things I get
to do is go do you not know this
comedian well you're an idiot because
they're [ __ ] amazing you know and I
want to continue to do that so I'd love
to be able to do a second season a nice
one and I really like Harley Quinn so if
people can watch that that'd be great
other than that I'm fine all right Ron
Funches is fine which is why we were so
grateful that you were willing to do
so man because you didn't have to do
this but we really do appreciate you for
doing this oh man in comedian was
talking about call me you know it's I
love I love talking about it especially
if you have really good questions and
you really care about the art form I
mean I we're cutting it short as far as
I'm concerned I always said 45 minutes
and I want to honor that so we we leave
them what more you know we will we'll
have you back again for season two
please oh all right well huh Pratt the
first go forth
check out Ron's show or don't he doesn't
need you just listen to these guys he
said so we can all make better comedy
out there so keep grinding out if you
watch the show oh yeah watch the show so
we can get a season two and he'll come
back on the show here so go watch the
show on kwibi
and listen to his podcast as well and
buy merch alright kids have fun out
there hop brother and sister and we'll
see you next week